♪ And you are, you are,
you are the reason ♪
♪ Why I'm still ♪
- Hmm, I have an idea.
Tyler, I need some blueberries.
- [Electronic Voice] One
minute, 37 seconds later.
(groovy music)
(blueberries thudding)
(opera singing)
- And this is WeeklyVee, five.
If you do not love losing, you lost.
♪ I feel I can't lose ♪
♪ I'm mortal, immortal, immortal ♪
(beep echoes)
- Monday morning, just
getting into the office
and it's already been,
what's good my guy?
It's already been a day.
A lot of fires this morning.
Just a lot of client stuff
a lot of VaynerX stuff but that's the name
of this fucking game.
Executive Life. ("Killy" by
Evil Eye) ♪ Go off this ♪
♪ Flames off the exhaust shit ♪
♪ Often yeah do this so often ♪
♪ I'm ballin' ♪
♪ They don't like the way I'm ballin' ♪
♪ Ballin' ballin' ballin' ♪
- Can you give your
perspective on the best way
to embrace chaos especially
in an enterprise business?
- Um, by putting things in perspective.
The way I deal with chaos
and the way that I would deal in chaos
if I was a upper-middle
leader in this team
right now is realizing
what's the alternative.
You're in control.
The reason chaos is easy for me
is I know I'm in control.
When a tornado, or a
hurricane, or a virus,
or sales drop breaks out, I'm in control.
Coronavirus, China sales are down.
We're in control, we get to sit in a room
and say what are we going
to do. Chaos, I love chaos.
Like, if Mike Tyson's running
at me and I'm a boxer,
that chaos, that's why Holyfield beat him.
You're in control.
Yeah, it's not fun or scary or whatever
but you can duck.
I'm most calm when there's the most chaos
because I go into a place in my mind
of like what's the worst that can happen?
What, I might die?
Oh no, then business?
Who gives a crap.
Put it in perspective.
Stop being scared.
So okay, so let me sleep on it.
Give me 24 hours, here's why,
I really think that's
a million dollar card
and within the next twelve months easy,
especially if I just, if,
so let me think, okay but like,
let me think, I'll call you tonight,
tell you everything I'm thinking
and then you may want to.
How many are there, eight?
All right talk to you soon, bye bye.
I might buy my first half
a million dollar card.
- Whoa.
- What are we going live on?
- Facebook, LinkedIn, Instagram
- And Tik Tok
- Twitter
(laughs)
- Awesome.
- All of 'em.
- [Hannah] Okay, first
question, how do you go about
streamlining to make
yourself more efficient,
second question--
- Wait, let me start
right there, I can answer you very quick.
- Okay.
- That one's easy.
If you don't judge yourself
for being inefficient
you become efficient.
I might be one of the most
inefficient people of all time,
but because I don't judge it,
I actually become remarkably efficient.
If people realize they spend more time
dwelling on being inefficient
than actually the efficient work,
everything would change.
- I've never thought
of it that way before.
- No shit.
That's why you asked it first.
- Well, there you go (laughs)
- Hannah, I'm being
really serious with you.
I'm going to sit on this
one for it's gonna help
a lot of people.
Everybody judges themselves arbitrarily,
all of a sudden, everybody thinks they're
an efficiency expert on them own selves.
All your doing is
driving home insecurities
and judgment on yourself on
something that doesn't matter.
It doesn't mean try not
to get more efficient.
But, just doing what you can,
like having a calendar
and doing the best you can
is just fine.
The second you don't get to
something on your calendar
and you beat yourself up,
is the second you're inefficient.
The dwelling that people put
on themselves around efficiency
is overwhelming to me
and ludicrous at best.
And dangerous at worst.
Next.
- That makes a lot of sense
thank you for that.
- Your welcome.
Vlog, what's up we're like fucking pumped
right now or you can
probably feel the energy
of the crew here.
Avishtap you were fired up.
For sure, just good.
Me at my best, for me,
my subjective opinion
about me is Q and A.
Where I have time, where I'm not rushed
the interrupted by it's
'cause it's a time frame
I feel rushed,
I'm trying to get the answers
I'm trying to get insights.
It fucks with you guys, you get mad at me.
Not a good format for me.
Q and A, great format for me.
I can dig, I can do
the follow up question.
It's less broad.
It goes deeper.
I show more stuff.
It helps, you can
associate with the people.
There's only 49 groups of people.
You see yourself in one or two of them.
It's good shit, I'm super pumped.
("Doing the Right Thing" by Borrtex)
- What's up bro?
- Yo, yo, what's up?
How you doing?
- Really good.
- Good.
- I called this meeting
because I'm really
impressed with your talent
and I need you to hear it from me
because I think, there's
just a lot of macro-moving
VaynerX things but I think
you've put in the work
and built the equity
for a really fun chapter.
I don't know what that
means just this second
but I want you to know
it's very much on my mind and radar.
- It's super fun.
- Good.
- Yeah.
- Good news is
you can keep doing exactly what,
but you're gonna get some
opportunities thrown at you.
I don't know exactly what that means
but I know I'm on third base, I'm cooking
which means in the next 30 to 75 days,
shit's gonna hit and you're
at the top of my mind.
- All right.
- Yeah it's, in the world
of like, running a company
where 93% of your shit
is fucking problems and fires and shit
and tough conversations,
it's awfully fun to have a 7% conversation
where it's good and it's going and listen,
I know how wired in you
are to the movement.
Your patience and execution
now becomes your advantage.
And your talent, you have it.
Yeah, that's it.
Hey guys, I'm just popping
up in the middle of this
so I get the end of this meeting.
It doesn't, I mean I don't
know how long that was,
but I know how you guys
are gonna post edit this.
It does not take a long time
to make an important impact
and I think a lot of bosses
wait for like "reviews"
and all sorts of dumb shit,
find micro moments to over communicate
both pros and cons.
That was a wildly efficient meeting
that will help both parties,
the organization and Brandon and so,
do more of that shit
if you run businesses.
That's what I got.
Anything I can answer for you?
- None I can think of.
- Good, you'll be hearing
a lot more from me.
Just keep executing.
We'll be in touch shortly.
- Cool, take it easy bro.
- Have a great day.
- You too.
Yo, what's up guys, this is Brandon.
I'm a content creator here at Vayner.
You guys just watched a
meeting that I had with Gary
and I wanted to kind of give
you guys some more insight
and some context to it.
So we were originally
slotted for like 15 minutes
and I was in there for
maybe like 90 seconds
and I think the take away there
and something I've started doing even
in my meetings is if I
think I need 30 minutes,
I'll actually make it 15,
because speed is everything
and cutting it down,
you can still get done
what you need to get done
in that amount of time.
So, I think that's kind of
a good take away from that.
So now, back to the vlog.
("Destiny" by Killy)
♪ Whatever goes around
will always come around ♪
♪ Down down ♪
- [Man Off Camera] What
are you doing here now?
- I'm calling an Uber because
we had a little travel
audible called this week
so Gary's driver is not
currently in New York City,
but he will be tomorrow
and in the mean time
I am taking over the vlog.
It is my vlog (laughs).
- Six views.
- That's so fucked up (laughs).
- I'm heading down to CNBC
to do a hit with Maha.
Hey Brandon, talking to
Brandon from Wine Library.
We're going to CNBC to do some content
around Superbowl at Business MX.
What's up B-Dub. ♪ Ain't nobody
praying for a kid like me ♪
♪ Better in the burbs than
to see in these streets ♪
- [Gary] Hello.
- Gary I've been such a big fan of yours
and watching your Instagram videos.
- [Gary] Thank you so much.
It's a pleasure to meet you.
- [Gary] Thank you my friend.
- Can I just take a photo?
- [Gary] Very quickly.
'Cause I'm going on air in a second.
- Yeah, yeah definitely, definitely.
♪ Pray for me pray for me pray for me ♪
♪ I've just been patiently
waiting for days ♪
- [Passerby] Hi Gary, how are you?
- Very good, how are you?
♪ Trying to see the vision
that I really don't care ♪
- Thank you bro.
♪ Better pray for my people
'cause we all equal ♪
♪ So now that D what I'm giving instead ♪
♪ Used to be a sheep
just trying to get by ♪
- We on CNBC in 10 minutes, in 12 minutes?
Ten minutes, 4:35 Eastern,
tune in to see if Caleb
gets the right shot.
(upbeat dance music)
- How much difference does that make it,
- A lot.
- Does it make it quite a cheap
slot? Relatively speaking.
- Oh, you know what's funny?
I'm the social media digital guy
and I continue and will always say
until things change in America
that the Superbowl ad
is grossly under priced
at 5.2 million dollars a slot
because of the dynamics
that you're referring to
and even without the internet,
it's the one time America
sits down and wants
to actually watch a commercial.
Every other moment of
our lives, we hate them.
♪ It's the beach boy coming
through city going hard ♪
♪ I got big money calling I'm
just trying to play it smart ♪
♪ Play it smart I'm just
trying to play it smart ♪
- [Interviewer] You
mentioned wanting to do more
traditional media now.
What's the thought process behind that?
- I've penetrated the internet
in a very significant way.
There's a lot of people that don't know me
in the 55 to 90 year old set
and the post-creative that we can chop up
is a good look back into
Digital so it's a cycle.
I'm unemotional about
where, it's all arbitrage.
Like, I keep telling
people, I don't give a fuck.
(bass heavy hip hop)
- I'm a huge fan, I just have to say
I watch your videos every single day
me and my roommate so I had,
can I get a picture with you?
- Mmkay.
- Oh my gosh.
Thank you so much for everything.
- Nice to meet you, nice
to meet you, thank you.
What is my life? (laughs)
(hip hop beat)
(echoed beep)
("Mojito" by Louis Futon)
- Yo, this is Sharrell,
videographer on Team GaryVee,
and today we have a bunch of footage
of confidential client meetings.
So what you're about to check out
is G on a radio interview,
he's talking about
baseball cards, flipping,
getting this money, so
get back to the vlog.
- Sports cards are exploding, Jim.
I need everybody who's listening right now
to really go to StockX and
eBay and see what's going on.
I've been investing in
sports cards for 18 months.
Last April and May and June,
I bought 50 Lebron rookies
and now they grade them.
You send them to a company.
They say if it's a perfect
ten, a nine, an eight.
I bought 50 perfect tens at $1,050 a piece
now they're selling for $4,000 a piece.
- [Jim] Wow, Gary give me a brief primer,
not knowing a lot about this
if I want to get my toe in--
- eBay, yep, (talks over Jim)
- What do I do?
- You go to Google
and you search sports cards you know,
why are sports cards going up?
Like you type in questions on Google,
then you go to eBay completed items
and you type in athletes,
Lamar Jackson rookie card
and you hit search and then
you hit completed items,
and you can see for the
last two, three months,
how much they've gone for.
Let me give you the comp there.
I wanted to do it and I sucked,
I missed, made a huge mistake,
I didn't take action 'cause
I liked Lamar's game.
I didn't think he was gonna
do what he did this year
but Lamar rookies in perfect 10s were $35
going into the season, now they're $300.
Last year I did it with
Giannas, I bought 'em at $180.
They're at $800 now.
So you go to eBay and StockX
and you look at the prices
and you look at completed
auctions and that gives you,
you spend four to ten hours
on that looking up athletes.
Most of the cards your
listeners and I grew up with
aren't worth anything because
it was during the junk wax era
where they made a million of these.
Now they make limited numbers of them
and the vintage graded
stuff is going great.
But there's three reasons.
45-year-olds now have 7-year-olds,
so they're reliving their childhood.
Gambling, you can buy a $200
pack of cards right now.
That's how much they can be now, Jim,
200 for one pack,
but you can pull a $150,000 Luca or Zion.
So gambling, and then finally sports cards
have a lot more volume than sneakers
so we have an entire
generation of teenagers
who are now in their twenties
that grew up flipping
Yeezes and Jordans who
now if they think that
Lamar Jackson's gonna be the guy,
they go out and buy 500,
2000, 4000 Lamar rookies,
and make $100,000 in nine months,
but I know that you have
like the best sports audience
and I'm just trying to think about
if somebody wants to do a side hustle
and you're listening to the burning
and your sitting there right now
and you're thinking about starting.
I know a lot of people now
wanna invest in start ups.
They wanna find their Facebook and Uber,
but that's 99% likely gonna fail,
or they love to gamble
and they're analytical
and they go to Daily
Fantasy and sports betting,
but that's high risk, high
return, you either win or lose,
it's binary, meanwhile
there's a ton of people
who are listening right now who know that
David Njoku was hurt this year
but he's a freak tight end and
he might come back next year,
or they think that, like I do,
that Sam Darnold's way better
than he actually has
shown because he's had
real difficulties with offensive line
and Joe Douglas has proven in Philly
that he's gonna build an offensive line
and what does that mean to him?
So, there's a ton to do on speculation
with limited downside and high upside
and so that's how I see it.
(bubbles bursts)
(beep echoes)
♪ No Sangria on the rocks ♪
♪ I don't got time for that ♪
♪ Mama got 20 years left on the clock ♪
♪ I only got time for that ♪
♪ I don't prefer them
sneakers or the socks ♪
♪ I don't got time for that ♪
- Just got into the Convention
center here in El Paso.
This is where UTEP plays.
Big shot out to Tim
Hardaway Sr., UTEP two step,
I remember you.
- Do you have any tips for
me as a small business owner
like myself and for a lot of--
- It's not, you know what's funny,
I never killed myself, I liked it so much.
- I enjoy it though.
I like being in--
- Yeah, everyone's like you bur--
I'm like, no I didn't, I liked it.
- I don't work.
- Like you want to play video games
and watch Netflix and I want
to ideate on my business side.
It's creative, I like it.
- So I'm not weird that
I like spreadsheets
and like doing my math and
like hawking my account?
- Of course not, most
people like stuff they,
and then, but for some
reason they either put things
on a pedestal or demonize them.
I don't understand why
people can't just understand
it's a self-awareness game.
I don't wanna be a starving artist
but somebody who loves the fuck out of it
I'm like, that's awesome.
I just don't understand
demonizing people's joys.
So what would I say to you,
I would say nothing
beats loving the process.
That's why I'm so, I'm 40, I love it,
bro, when I tell you, you've
said two things already,
bro, I've never ever ever
thought about the money
for real, for real, for real.
And I've lived it
like people are like yeah,
back to like, I'm like, but I lived it.
I worked every fucking day
until I was 34 years old
for my dad and left
with nothing, zero, zero
and then I started a company
with my 11 year younger brother
I had all the leverage and we went 50/50.
Right, and like I just,
if you love your game,
you've won. It will all be there.
I've never had more leverage to make money
and I've never been cooler,
and I'm fucking 44 and that's
not what you think at 26.
How old are you?
- [Youth Off Camera] I'm 16.
- That's not what you're
thinking at 26 and 16.
When I was 26 and 16, 44
was dead, old, fucking--
- You know, I can't wait 'til I'm 44 bro.
- Fair enough, but I remember being 22
coming to my dad's liquor
store and my cousin was 30,
and I was like this dude's old.
(slow music)
- [Crowd member] And I actually graduated
from this university and--
(crowd cheers)
I barely ever finished, I was a C student.
I went homeless and I
didn't have any social media
'cause all that shit happened
and then I went back home where my parents
had kicked me out and I
found this right there
in my mail and this is
how I discovered you.
I wanted to be a marketer
now I'm a national marketing manager.
I run 387 stores for Cricket.
I'm still progressive
(cheers)
I bought my home, I'm
still short on the cash,
so I got a second job now.
- Good for you.
- I'm in Texas for anybody that needs it.
- By the way, real quick,
real quick, real quick,
don't worry bro, it's
all good, we're all--
(crowd laughs)
I'm going to make a point right now
that's gonna really, really resonate.
A lot of people have been up
here and said a lot of things
and a lot of different claps happened.
My man right here just going
through his story, right?
It was super interesting.
He's going through his
story and he just said
I got a second job and
not a clap in the place.
And I think about that shit
because literally out of
almost everything I've heard
from every person tonight.
The number one thing
that made my chemicals go
into wanting to cheer was when he said,
"I got a second job."
Having the humility to
do that is so powerful.
We cheer the wrong things.
Yay (claps), you got a cool new hoodie.
And we don't cheer the real shit
like I got a second job
and that's how I listen
when it doesn't seem obvious.
I listened to the fact that
none of you clapped for it.
And that makes me say
this doesn't have enough
awareness to how powerful it is.
Which then gets me into
until we clap for humility
we will not understand
the foundational piece
to success.
I have too much swag and
bravado and competitiveness
to make it obvious to you that humility
is my super power but
somebody's going to come along
that might not be as cursing and as rugged
and as alpha and as male and as Jersey
and they're going to and
I'm going to be super happy
when she or he comes along
because I promise you
if you leave with anything tonight.
Humility is the foundation of happiness.
(audience applauds)
So it's 10:34 in El Paso which means its
12:34 in New York and we're in Texas
and we'll be in the office at 10am.
El Paso, WeeklyVee, it's
been a long fucking day.
(beep echoes)
- Yo what's up guys this is
Brandon I was filming Gary today
and something that I think
is super interesting is
that for 60% of the day I
wasn't even allowed to record
audio and then for another
30% I couldn't even
turn on the camera whatsoever
just for confidential
reasons and then really 10% of his day
is what you're going to see in WeeklyVee
and I think it's interesting because
I think a lot of people
see Gary as maybe a speaker
when really he's the
CEO of VaynerMedia first
and he's getting a lot of
shit done throughout the day
and that was a lot of his day today.
♪ Do your own thing ♪
♪ See how that goes ♪
♪ That's what I did, yeah
♪ ♪ That's what I do ♪
- Hey I'm Claude Silver,
I'm the chief heart officer
here at VaynerMedia.
So today we have an
incredible leadership meeting
where Gary was sharing his vision for 2020
and all of the leaders around the table
were sharing their vision
how it fits into the macro
of what we're doing here at
VaynerMedia in 2020, 2021
and it's such a powerful, powerful feeling
when you have everyone like
humming to the same tune.
Slightly different tones and harmonies
but the same tune,
and it's gonna be a
freaking phenomenal year.
- We cheer for you heavy.
- Thank you, thank you.
- For real for real.
- What book are you reading
right now man? What are you on?
- I don't read books.
- Word?
- Word.
- Crazy.
- That's not how I learn.
- [Man] He just writes them.
- He just writes them (laughs)
That's lit, I don't
read books I write 'em.
- You know when I, you know how I learn?
I read comments and I read DMs.
I learn, I'm, like this is
why I so relate to Boyd.
I'm, the way that Boyd's
got his ear to the streets
and hip hop and Lat-trap
and shit like that.
I have my ear to the
streets on a human level.
That's why I know shit to poke out,
'cause people write it to me and I read
and I watch and I watch how,
when you were on the MTV awards thing
and did your thing. I
read every single tweet.
All of them, all of them.
I didn't even watch your performance.
It was in the background
as it was happening.
You were on and I was
reading tweets in real time
about you.
- Crazy.
- I don't consume the thing.
I consume the people consuming the thing.
- Their reaction.
- That's how I always know shit.
Got it?
- [Team Member] Reaching the value
and putting out for new content.
- Correct, I put out content to learn.
I put out a post on Instagram this morning
that I know isn't really
made for Instagram
about how you should
run commercials on Hulu
and Amazon but I need to read the comments
to understand how they understood it.
I'm in fucking constant
motion of information.
I'm always talking because
I'm always listening.
- That sentence is lit (laughs).
- [Man At Table] Quotable.
- Take it, use it and then reference.
(electronic music)
- Yeah, so I like I
started a YouTube channel
and one of the questions
I wanted to ask you was
I'm having trouble finding a niche because
I do so much shit, like
obviously I play football.
- I don't think you need to find a niche.
I think your niche is that
you are that human being.
Football, after effects, small town kid,
I'm sure 17 other things
you haven't told me yet.
Your niche is you the human.
And everybody's like, oh, I need a niche
which actually means I need
to stay narrow in something
and just talk about football.
That's the reverse, you need
to be as broad as possible
but fully you which becomes your niche.
That's me.
I talk about the Jets, I
talk about sports cards,
I talk about wine, I talk
about business, right?
I'm not niche, I'm broad as fuck.
My niche is that I'm Gary.
That's your fucking niche.
Your niche is you the human.
Everyone's holding back their full self
and then they're like okay,
I'm only showing people three parts
of me and then I got to pick
one so they go this narrow
instead of being them and that
actually is the macro-niche.
- I see what you're saying
'cause everyone on YouTube
like watching how to grow and shit,
it's all about you need to pick a niche,
like be SEO, that's how you do stuff.
- That's transactional,
that's how you get subscribers
and views but long term
don't build actually something meaningful.
- Yeah, 100%
- Right.
- Fuck yeah.
- Do you understand?
- 100% yeah.
- Dude you think I ever
thought I was going to
show my garage sale content?
- Yeah. Like when I first put
that out everyone was like,
literally some people were like
that's some crazy shit and
then a lot of other people
were like you can't, like my real friends,
not my real friends, not my
real friends at all actually
my real serious business
acquaintances called me
and was like, this looks stupid.
You're making yourself look stupid.
I'm like you're fucking stupid.
- Yeah, it's not about that.
- I'm not posturing out here.
I'm not worried what people think.
I fucking garage sale.
I like buying stuffed animals for a dollar
and selling them for nine.
That's what I'm about
and I think a lot of people
are scared to go there.
Like the me's of the world
want to show a private plane
you know?
The me's of the world, aka
got a little something going
they want to show a BMW,
they want to show court side.
I'm the like the reverse, I'm
like fucking having random
meetings with kids in
the back seat of my car.
- Yep, and the reason
you are who you are is
'cause you hustle like
that like at garage sales
and you flip shit
- That's right and
- It's about value.
- And it's about value, you got it.
I want to help people.
You know why I started
showing my garage sale stuff
because a lot of people DMed me saying
yeah, whatever but I have no money.
I'm like cool, I had no
money most of my life.
Let me show you how I did it.
- Yeah (laughs) so sick.
- Right, here's what you
do when you have 20 bucks.
You make it 400 bucks.
How, being humble and
grinding like a fucker.
400 becomes 4000, 4000 becomes 40,000
and then you got a little
nut, now you can do something.
- Dang this is surreal.
So Ruggles knows someone on your team
and I was like is there any chance
like I'm going to be in New York.
I got a job interview I
actually just got out of
like an hour ago.
- For the summer?
- Yeah for the summer internship.
- Do you want internship at Vayner?
- Fuck yeah, like are you
fucking kidding me, 100%?
- I'm not, I'm dead serious.
- Dead ass serious?
- I'm going to make
this real, real serious.
Avi when are we there?
- [Avi] 3:35.
- Okay, I need to do a bunch of shit.
I've given you what I needed to
plus I've given you the biggest thing.
I will get you an
internship at 137 or Vayner
if you jump out of the fucking car now
so I can have 20 minutes
to get my shit done.
- Fuck yeah, done.
Thank you so much sir.
- Real pleasure man,
- Can I get pictures before I go?
I'll see you this summer man, 100%
- All right.
- Wanna check it.
Make sure you got it.
- All right, hell yeah.
- I'll see you soon,
send me an email.
- Sounds good.
- I'll get that coup
rolling for the summer.
- Appreciate it.
- Talk to you.
- On fire.
- Just life now.
- [Brandon] Can I get
you to speak to the vlog
just in general about today Gary
just like what happened, like meetings.
- Well today was a super
operational day, Brandon,
you know, I think this week
is kind of interesting.
I'm not sure how epic the vlog is gonna be
because it's fucking been
an operational week heavy
outside of the quick
trip to El Paso, right?
We've been fucking
operations VaynerX world
and I can feel it, this
has been an epic week
of ops and really excited about it so
just getting a lot of work done
that's going to really impact the business
and I can feel it
and I'm going to a big
meeting here at Spotify now
just I'm in an interesting zone.
I don't know if you can
like feel it at your level
or like, I know your close
to so many people on my team.
I'm in a very focused zone.
It's a lot more operations
than people think.
- [Brandon] That's what I
was getting ready to say
I still feel like people,
even though we put out so much content
and we put out seven
and a half hour vlogs,
I still feel like a lot of
people still don't realize--
- Yeah, people think I'm an influencer,
motivational speaker, it's funny.
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
(game show cheery music)
(beep)
- The amount of times I type out pedestal
and never even get close
to spelling it right
is remarkable.
P-E-D-E-S-T-A-L, pedestal.
I can get my own Uber.
- Are you sure?
- He can order it.
- I'm a functional human, I was joking.
- Eight, seven, six, five, four,
- My husband doesn't believe
I'm actually on the phone with
you. He's sitting next to me
- What's his name?
- His name's Daniel.
- Hey Daniel.
- What's up.
- What's up bro, it's really me bro,
this is not an automated message.
- [Daniel] It sounds like you.
- It's really me bro, I promise.
- [Daniel] That's cool.
- It is cool, you're cool.
(woman laughs)
- And G's just talking about
flipping cards, getting money,
(laughs) what am I doing?
Jason I hate this so much.
- [Photographer] Ready one, two, three.
- DRock, you missed it with the grab.
Guy grabbed the five,
so I wanna make sure we get that part.